c'est bon vous avez jamais pensé à à
reprendre le hit machine ça vous des
idées
il ya des idées c'est oui on va se
parler tout charlier a travaillé tout
l'été sur un projet machine chaoui noter
près un diffuseur on y arrive en cas
diffuseur la musique la musique c'est
cesta nom nadir diffuseurs et de 2002
1995 à 2000
toutes les plus grandes stars
internationales et françaises sont
venues chanter sur votre plateau david
guetta et usher britney spears et spice
girls vous souvenir prins principal et
catherine se maria carey aussi marie
carré
elle était venue puis il ya toujours une
liste de demandes
ils vont pas à l'antenne et donc dans la
lys y avait trois lettres se priver pour
marié attiré forcément n'a pas donc
lille est une bonne idée en fait c'est
d'écrire sur les toilettes
mariah carey ont tout le temps à qui
arrêtait là c'était sauver ses toiles et
ses toiles personnes avaient droit une
autre personne a même droit à wemmel a
été aux toilettes
[Rires]
alors ça ça va vous plaire regardez
regardez les images
le hit machine franchement ça nous
manque on en parlait ce matin se sont
dits oui je vous lis regarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aïe
très mal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors tous les gens sont très très
content de vous voir il ya juste eu un
petit souci avec un téléspectateur qui a
envoyé un tweet qu'on va voir tout de
suite je viens de 1 pen ne reconnaît
plus lus depuis tout à l'heure
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]